[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight one thing we know for
sure about elizabeth warren above all
else is that on economic questions he
say sincere populist Warren is deeply
distressed by income inequality she
profoundly distrust Wall Street and big
tech she hates monopolies and massive
multi-generational concentrations of
wealth so if you're a private equity
chieftain for example or a weed smoking
trustafarian living off family money in
Jackson Hole you've got to be terrified
of Elizabeth Warren how could you not be
terrified listen to her talk now they've
got their fortunes and their money
managers and their PR and they're
getting richer faster and faster and
faster and everybody else is getting
left behind the wealth tax the two-cent
wealth tax I love that wealth tax right
I'm not willing to give up and let a
handful of monopolist dominate our
economy and our democracy it's time to
fight back it's time to fight back
against the monopolist who dominate our
economy sound familiar
well actually that's not too far from
what Donald Trump ran on in 2016 back
before Paul Ryan and the Aisne rand
people got ahold of his economic program
but this time around Elizabeth Warren
plans to steal that message the Trump
message really warned claims that she's
the radical populist chair she's the
disrupter but is she
let's see Emily Tish Sussman is a woke
liberal who often appears on cable
television to talk about democratic
politics nice person but she's the
daughter of two billionaires so you'd
think that Emily - Sussman would hate
Elizabeth Warren but she doesn't
instead she demands that you support
Elizabeth Warren or else you're sexist
watch I actually heard overheard someone
saying that I thought was an interesting
point that basically at this point if
you are still supporting standards as
opposed to Warren it's kind of
your sexism because she has more
detailed plans and her plans have
evolved I thought it was an interesting
point and I think there may be something
to it yeah there might be something to
if you don't support Warren you're a
sexist now keep in mind you just saw one
of the richest people on planet Earth
demanding that you support Elizabeth
Warren for president surprising right
well actually it turns out that some of
Warren's most fervent supporters are the
very people she claims she wants to
fight well that's weird so for example
in the third quarter of this year
Elizabeth Warren raised more money from
Silicon Valley from those monopolists
she claims to hate than anybody else
running for president
Spotify CEO is an Elizabeth Warren fan
so with Silicon Valley venture
capitalist and billionaire Chris Sacca
he's already maxed out to her campaign
really the billionaire is supporting her
then last month Charlie gasps Brenna
over on Fox Business reported that
Elizabeth Warren's campaign is making
overtures to finance moguls on Wall
Street seeking contributions and some of
them are responding but wait a second
why would Elizabeth Warren's enemies and
these have got to be her enemies she
attacks them all the time on the
campaign trail why would her enemies
fund her campaign we'll give you five
seconds to think about and the answer of
course is they're not really her enemies
they understand that Warren doesn't
really mean what she says they know that
Warren's populism is a facade and
underneath it all she's really just this
season's Hillary Clinton faithful party
robots tilework defend her the
prerogatives of the establishment that's
what it seems like she really is is she